what is your skin type handsome
hey gq it's rihanna and i'm going face
to face
with asap rocky
all right ring ring ring ring what's up
riri
what's up right hey how are you i'm
good how are you doing i'm chilling so i
need to ask you the same stuff
what is your favorite
i just wanted to say the same thing it
means so
much in four letters yeah it's also i
mean like
really no but it can mean like
like you know i just like dropped my you
know my glasses juice so like
yeah it could mean that it could also
mean that true but i like
better like like uh yes
a food that you would never eat under
any
circumstance chitlins i just want to say
an intestine of any animal like that's
just like
come on that's no bueno like i want to
say celery and then i was like now i
could get through that my life depended
on it
animals
i don't know
i'm with you unless it's good for your
skin
agree to agree what's the hardest part
about working with
me i think the hardest part about
working with shoes is not
goofing off and laughing the whole time
like this is comedy
that's the hardest part you know be such
people be so cool it's just hard not to
not to laugh that's all but it was fun i
know the hardest part is not having too
much fun you just forget that it's
still you know work at the end of the
day yeah that's good
what is your self-care routine and how
do you take care of yourself
my self-care routine would be
showering taking care of my skin
exfoliating moisturizing
just cleansing myself grooming trimming
anytime i could you know it's a pandemic
right now so i've been chilling on all
that but
for the most part yeah so
when you discover skincare you were how
old
[Music]
probably like 14 15.
what's the first product you bought like
was it a moisturizer or like a
a face wash yeah my first time really
getting introduced to like
the skin care platform i think i was
like younger and it was through like a
rinse magazine
my mother had it in the drawers like a
cleanser
yeah it was like a cleanser it was cool
what's your last purchase under twenty
dollars
condoms
i bought a t-shirt for like eleven
dollars oh
it was tight i came up on it yeah where
does a stock
buy a t-shirt for eleven dollars i take
a free t-shirt my favorite price is free
99.
what is your skin type handsome
so is that like an oily hand
a combination handsome or just like a
sensitive
handsome it's a handsome handsome man
you know handsome all right so is your
skin
ashy dry oily or
sensitive i would say i have very
sensitive skin
for sure so do you usually get like uh
really cautious about using certain
products and stuff like that when it
comes to
your skin since it's so sensitive yeah
for sure
you know stuff that's just like too much
alcohol basing it all
like way too much chemicals you know
break you out
even worse you know i'm saying so for me
it was just like
i had to discover face cleansing
and skin care all at the same time when
i was a young buck in a shower
okay so who's like the first person that
you
looked up to in terms of skin care in
regards to like
a man skin care is like weird to say
that about but like
who have you looked at and try to just
emulate
your skin care regimens
personally no man no men
really right no unfortunately i ain't
i didn't even know that was a thing like
let me ask you something like you know
how
we find out as we get older like girls
love men with like
manicures and pedicures and stuff like
that for real for
is skin care big thing with when it
comes to women
i mean women always love members because
skin i mean come on
but as much as you guys think about your
your nails and your skin
we think about that too we we look at
that
we enjoy men that
take care of their skin their nails
because it says
a lot about like how they'll take care
of themselves and the people around them
so of course it's a big deal for us
dang that's what's up i guess it does
reflect a lot about your personality
or especially in my household my mother
my brothers could not
have their nails at a certain length
they had to be clean they had to be
short they had to be
filed my mother was that kind of woman
so like i
i think i've kind of adopted that
point of view from her that's what's up
what was your first red carpet same
thing it was
mtv that's a big deal straight off the
bat with that yeah my first rate carpet
was mtv
i know what i had on i could tell you
what i had on no i don't need to hear it
i just need to see it
you could describe it as as i'm seeing
it no no no it was bt
it was bt i think it was the bt wars it
wasn't out i see i confused it
for that year when we now so it was a
month before it was bt
the first red carpet oh my god
is this your first black on black yeah
so i had right there the hermes building
when i had the rav sent me
no you don't have to plan a hermes and
raf this is you
and then i had the uh the black scale
hat on with
nah stop trying to make it sound dope
this is you
you know it you know what i'm saying
look at that handsome fella yeah that's
me
check me out you could've used some
fancy skin back then
what's your favorite offer of me i ain't
gonna lie
my favorite outfit of you the red carpet
at the british
fashion awards earlier this year
really i ain't gonna lie like that look
like ever
like of all of my red carpets are like
videos that
that that's my that's one of my favorite
look damn
what you ain't like that one no i love
that look i'm just like i'm shocked that
that's what you would say
it's not like wrath or like rake nah it
was fire
high tops or little tops it's gonna have
to be hot tops
high tops for me what's your favorite
[ __ ] of watching the tv
i watch everything man that's a complex
question for a complicated guy man
i watch everything you know cartoon
i like i like to watch cartoons as weird
as it is
the older the better vintage cartoons
that's my vibe i could binge
watching those family what's your
favorite vintage
cartoons to watch like pop by the sailor
man
scooby doo obviously the jetsons
banana splits wait till your father gets
home
betty boop you know stuff like that but
we can't give the sauce away too much
you know
i love better betty boop so far she's so
fine
how do you stay mentally and
inspirationally aligned
i think for me i'm just more of a people
person you know
to stay mentally and inspirationally in
line
i think it it kind of takes it starts
with the mental
i think you got to be in a good mental
space to even allow yourself to be
inspired you know because
it's all about like what you said you
know you got to allow things into your
universal world your space you know
yeah wow that's kind of deep
nah i mean you saying the same but you
know no that's actually
better answer than man can i just like
can i ever do
no yeah
man so like i just try to keep the
mental capacity to stay inspired and not
too influenced
yeah so what's your favorite product so
far from the
fancy skincare line i'm gonna have to go
with the moisturizer this invisible
moisturizer whatever you want to call it
yeah i love it i ain't even gonna lie
the mechanism is crazy
it's different and it smells good you
know
thank you put it all over your hands
you can't be having no dry hands talking
to nobody you know what i mean i'll be
ashy in between the knuckles and all
that that ain't the vibe
when it comes to skincare what are you
packing your travel bag
when it comes to skincare i pack mostly
moisturizers
a little bit of face soap
yeah that's really it i don't really use
much toners and stuff when i'm traveling
really face wipes too they don't really
take much me
what do you wish more people were
talking about
in the beauty industry
what i wish more people would talk about
in the beauty industry
i would have to say i wish that it was
more versatility
diversity obviously you know i think
it's
kind of trying to evolve especially with
a person like yourself and what you
doing in amongst the
beauty industry but i do wish that there
was way more you know versatility
throughout it all you know i feel like
everything is very
old-fashioned and kind of stuck to old
blueprint and
as tom evolves so does you know the
blueprint
honestly thank you so much for even
being a part of this conversation
where we could discuss openly
skin care for for men for women for
non-binary we just think everyone with
skin deserves to have great skin and
i appreciate you being a part of this
conversation so
yo you more than welcome the pleasure
online i want to say thank you for
you know supporting me at a time when i
just came home from jail thank you for
identifying my
beauty as a man you know what i'm saying
i appreciate you like
like for real ferretto you know and
thanks for the opportunity
well shout out to gq thank you so much
for being involved in this conversation
between rocky and i face to face this
was tight
thank you so much all right y'all
if y'all want to see the tables turn go
to vogue.com to see me ask rihanna all
these questions face to face
you